so i was i was looking today cnn
reported about how pelosi's
special committee on january 6th right
because that's what we're doing now she
reported about how they are now trying
to get telecommunications companies to
fork over
uh phone records for like hundreds of
people including a bunch of um members
of congress members of congress yeah
like mostly gop
legislators like matt goetz and uh
lauren bobert and jim jordan and jim
banks the people that she cut from the
committee in the first place after
mccarthy appointed them
and cnn reported uh the
the committee's investigation into the
deadly riot of january 6th
they keep saying this deadly riot thing
over and over and they refuse to ever
just print where a police officer shot
an unarmed woman to death with no
warning or provocation this is this this
is one of the darkest stories like i
gotta tell you to be completely honest
from cnn january 6 committee to ask
telecommunications companies to preserve
phone records of members of congress who
participated in stop the steel rally
they're doing increments yes they
they're preserving the records because
they don't want to come out right they
did a black lives last tweet did you see
that a blacklist they did a they did a
roundup they demanded all of the
correspondence between oh that's not a
black list a number of conservative it
was like conservative journalists and
influencers
and a bunch of people in the trump
administration and associates there
right yeah this is the next level so
they're doing it one step at a time
first it's you know we want this
information from the government on these
individuals the trump administration and
all the activists who helped demand
their communications yeah that they
pulled from they're trying to pull down
the archives they want phone records
preserved which means give it a week and
they'll say okay now we want those phone
records that's correct
so this is
and they're throwing we talk about the
collapse of afghanistan but this is the
uh this is the collapse the u.s no no
horrifying to watch this unfold
and what we're seeing is that they don't
actually have any evidence of the thing
that they believe happened right there's
no one charged with insurrection that's
exactly right there's very few people
charged with assault there were like
very few people charged with a previous
conspiracy right and the previous
conspiracy people were like
known members of uh
you know radical organizations
i mean it's like they said
the fbi report said there's no there was
no coordination of central planning
evidence
yeah i said there was some evidence to
indicate people planned on breaking into
the building but no actual plan for what
that would entail that's right so
people smack talking on the internet i
guess that's basically it and mostly
they were doing it on facebook and
friends and they pulled parlor down to
punish parlor for facebook's sins and
from this
we are now getting the democratic party
going after
their rivals their political opponents
and everything they accuse trump of
doing they are doing right now
that's correct so this is the end
i can't i can't see how
uh a country can lose in afghanistan
considering the past examples of the
collapses of countries after falling out
failing in afghanistan okay maybe that's
unfair but man was that bad it could
shatter this the empire yeah for sure
like the soviet union cracked but russia
remains so like
even a search warrant you need to have
probable cause and say what you're
looking for in this committee they're
not even saying what they're looking for
because they don't actually have any
idea how they're going to prove that
january 6 was a white supremacist
conspiracy to overthrow the government
they don't care about that they want
phone records because those phone
records will then leak
yes they want all of it because they
don't know what they're looking for i
mean we're at the age of just don't use
a phone don't use don't use unencrypted
communication right
yeah that that funny story we always uh
peop people know it better than i do but
that story about the war game they did
where like the older guy went up against
the younger guys and the older guy won
because he sent communications by a
motorcycle with a written note and they
were trying to do digital and they
couldn't track it or something like that
it's a funny story yeah but um
you can't not use a phone you know what
i mean you but you can use things like
signals telegram and signal yeah
telegram and signal you can you can set
up custom operating systems you can
learn how to flash you know different
operating system on your phone it's not
the easiest thing in the world but it's
not particularly difficult but i think
the bigger issue here is it's not about
it's not about looking for evidence what
they're doing is they're saying for one
if you oppose us we'll dig through all
your records we know those records will
leak to the press whether it's social
media or telecommunications and more
importantly they're looking for strategy
they wanted information on all of these
people from april 2020 to january 2020
right once they have the uh
once they have that information could
people just put in foia requests for it
i don't well so the issue with the first
request on social media was that they
want government communications things
that already exist right so
entirely possible now that they've made
national archive stuff now that they've
made the announcement that these things
potentially exist i'm sure buzzfeed
already went to town subpoenaing every
single one of these individuals it's
it's actually there's a funny thing that
i did at vice once we wanted to do we
never actually did we were planning it
was to do a four request on ourselves
and see what comes up and then whoever
gets the biggest stack is the winner
north korea venezuela you'd wonder who
has the bigger you know fbi file or
whatever
so uh but you can easily do this you can
now fully request saying like oh the
democrats
requested this i would like public
information you know these documents to
be related to the public on all of these
individuals and what they were saying
and
it's going to leak regardless of foreign
well the national archives i don't think
have turned over the information yet i
think they have to like september 9th
it'll happen you think so it's the
second request congr the uh committee
asked for it i think some of it back in
march or something yes so some of it's
uh a lot of the request is new some of
it didn't get turned over but i think it
will interesting
before no i think they just didn't do it
i don't know i mean the national
archives they're probably sitting there
like really we got to do something why
it's a lot of work the cia
the cia can look at anybody's info at
any time without a request that they can
do like a kangaroo court and get a foia
or whatever that fisa yeah fisa
um but congress has to get uh permission
as this is what we're learning right um
because they have subpoena power yeah i
mean this committee has that power
they could just subpoena but i think
they're slow rolling it that's why
they're saying preserve records yeah
that's why they're not saying we demand
all records immediately they're slow
rolling it so that people don't get
shocked they want the frogs to boil not
jump out of the pot right
those are these are these are
truly dark i know it's annoying i
thought the government was going to help
me also the
also the uh
the dirt of course i was like
in the u.s oh really i thought you meant
like recently i was like oh no way dude
for like last 30 years i was like sweet
right i was like after everything you've
said like government's awesome aren't we
still waiting for the durham report to
come out also because the
[Laughter]
um
but i think it was due already to you
you were like for a second they're like
serious
i caught on i got on pretty quick yeah
that's not gonna happen after i was in a
little car wreck today you know oh man
i don't think there's going to be a
durham report right you saw a uh
four-car pileup you were talking about
this oh yeah yeah
it was it was behind me that's crazy you
barely avoided it we were like fast and
furious and you like drifted and the car
flew over you you're like
you rose up out of the car and your
screen lays down no there was this crazy
truck driver he didn't break in time he
smashed into a whole bunch of people and
the car behind me like smashed into
smashed into us and then i hit the gas
and we like got out of there did you
fear for your life at any time in that
kind of yeah
i'm a new driver i'm a neutral i've only
been driving for like less than a year
now like we talked politics yeah yeah
but like when your life is on the line
look at these people in louisiana right
now with this hurricane we didn't even
talk about that how many people are
stranded right now haven't roofs coming
off of hospitals dude i remember that
that one in was 2003 the the hurricane
that george bush katrina katrina and
they they they mishandled that terrible
other people died from in that people
were on their moves yeah now we're truly
entering the panopticon drone footage
flying overhead filming people looting
buildings oh wow in louisiana so
speaking of surveillance
and then shutting down the the air space
over that wreckage earlier is probably
because they don't want the panopticon
right yeah yeah i think we're headed
towards a future where there's going to
be drones over your backyard you're
going to be in your bathroom and the
government drone's going to like flock
to the window and you're going to be
like naked it's going to be like do not
be alarmed citizen
we are simply doing an id check and
you're going to be like okay it's not
going to be the government drone it's
going to be amazon
or tesla well maybe not tesla apple
tesla's going to have some kind of weird
musk type implosion situation but it's
definitely going to be amazon saying
stay in your homes we will bring you the
things that you require
that that was uh what what what show was
i watching i think those electric dreams
that the one i was talking about a
little bit where it's like the uh the
the ai system wipes out humidity by just
mass producing products of want and so
then eventually humans are just
strangled out from the dying environment
and they're like the machines just drop
boxes of random garbage but i i think
i think what what we'll likely see is
with moves like this over the uh you
know january 6 they're going after
politicians they're going after
prominent activists this really does
paint a picture of that future where
amazon is like there's a uniparty like
we had a uniparty for some time but
they'll lucratively merge with the likes
of amazon or whatever well that's
already happening i mean when you see
you know the administration was asked if
they were going to do vaccine passports
and they said no there will be no
vac federal vaccine credential right but
then they supported states doing it they
supported cities doing it and they have
been encouraging businesses to do it
themselves so you see that they're
they're already teaming up they're
already creating this corporate federal
infrastructure that is horrible
horrifyingly difficult to
get out of like the ccp yeah
you know i think that's real i mean this
is something i think is definitely
happening and it's happening with all of
our acquiescence we like having
little pieces of garbage delivered to
our homes i just watched this really
amazing classical movie it's called um
it's called uh
fast and furious
one of the classics and there's i have
never i've never seen this film it's
good it's you got to see it you know why
because i was watching it and the bad
guy's name is reyes no hold on listen
okay the bad guy's name is reyes okay
and he's a brazilian like crime lord and
he was in the beginning of the movies is
really it's a profound moment i was
thinking about this he was talking to
these two guys and he says you know i
don't want to work with you your your
methods are too violent you know when
you get violent and you back someone
into a corner they have nothing left to
lose and they fight back
i give them something to lose and then i
own them and i was like wow yeah that's
that's that's something big like who i i
didn't think i was going to get any kind
of philosophy
fast and furious but to say like
give the people something to lose and
then threaten to take it away
that's why the americans don't want to
fight that's why people don't want to i
mean i'm not speaking for everyone here
yeah there's too much to lose
like a nuclear war would i mean yeah the
people and somalia would lose stuff but
we would no no no no look look at the
people who trespass and are getting six
months in prison and most of them were
like bankrupt already a lot of these
people had nothing
you know i think ashley babbitt for
example
was like facing bankruptcy so these are
people like reyes said and fast and
furious who had nothing left to lose
and so now they're saying that what
they're doing to these people is a
reminder you still have something left
to lose we will lock you up and torture
you in solitary confinement for eight
months
and then you'll realize what you've got
to lose and people are gonna see that
that's the message they're sending give
the people something to lose and you
will own them it's messed up did you see
what remember you know adam kokesh did
you see what they did to him back a
couple few years ago he went to dc and
protested with a shotgun an open carry
and they were like well that gives us
you know um what do they call it when
they have probable cause yeah probable
cause to search your apartment so they
went to his house and they found
mushrooms in his apartment threw him in
prison for mushrooms just devastated him
and he came out a completely different
person like he does not talk crap about
the government anymore yeah terrifying
because he was a hardcore actress
ex-military
they just look for it they bring the
hammer when they come he doesn't do any
anti-government i shouldn't say any but
he's not the outspoken vocalist that he
was in the early days like screaming
profanity-laced tirades about the
military industrial complex because of
mushrooms
we're gonna have a medical did you see
how uh the government wants to
expand the federal
reach into uh medical research no that's
awesome for
what for mushrooms
for all of it really yeah well there you
go
this is part of uh this is part of uh
biden's infrastructure plan is it's like
billions of dollars to create
uh more federal medical infrastructure
so i don't like it either and the idea
is that when we need vaccines we would
just have the government do it we
wouldn't have to
you know engage american industry in
doing these things in a competitive way
i was talking to a friend
and
they were saying something to me like
this is kind of a lefty person they're
like i'm really scared about what's
happening with these these coveted
numbers skyrocketing and i was like
i get it but i'm like at what point do
you just stop believing everything
because of how much they've been wrong
you know what i mean i'm not not to say
don't believe the numbers or anything
i'm just like at a certain point don't
you throw up your arms in futility like
i've done everything they've said
nothing's changed we we got vaccinated
we wore two masks it's all the same and
and they just keep blaming other people
and the response was like but the
government's really really scared and
that freaks me out and so it's like
i don't know i guess there are some
people there's there's two ways you can
go when you come to the futility of like
i just don't know anymore i'm i'm broken
mentally on this one i've seen too much
reverse like reversions and back and
forth i'm just like you go do your thing
i don't even know but then other people
say i give up just tell me what to do i
don't want to think anymore i think that
is the point i think it's an intentional
confusion so once you you know once we
give up logic we have nothing and the
regulations and the rules that are
coming down to us don't make any
cohesive sense they're not based on
anything right and so if you look to for
example absurdist literature from
eastern europe during the cold war if
you look at like kafka or if you look at
vaclav havel right who was brilliant
playwright who
ended up president of the czech republic
randomly um after the velvet revolution
but you can see in this literature
uh
where these writers have discovered um
or they rather elucidate the way that
communism
worked in those nations where it's like
they tell you one thing and then they do
something else like if you look at uh
the trial right did you read kafka's
trial so
i read this in high school um
and
uh i had to convince them to let me read
it but whatever so this guy
k ends up on trial and he can never get
any real information as to what he's on
trial for what it's about
who his solicitor is
what the punishments are going to be
it's all just very confusing and it's
very much like in metamorphosis where he
becomes the bug right so the guy we can
this is probably easier to explain but
so he becomes he wakes up one morning
he's a cockroach he's horrified that
he's a cockroach he doesn't know what to
do about it he goes all through how am i
going to explain this what am i going to
do i don't know as soon as he accepts
the fact that he's a cockroach and
nothing makes any sense and there's no
way out of it that's the end that's sort
of that's kind of the whole thing he's
like i'm going to go eat some garbage no
he just kind of dies he like dies under
his bed i think well that's brutal well
yeah but that's
that's what this is if they confuse you
enough if they make you so confused that
you stop questioning it because to
question itself is going to make you
crazy that's sort of the end goal
because then you don't question then you
just do what you're told you just show
up where you're supposed to show up you
hand over what they tell you to hand
over and in return you get to what like
have a drink on smith street and watch
the simpsons yeah yeah watch the simpson
and like jerk off right you get to do
that too i studied about these they even
gave everyone their only fans back
they're like we can't take that away
it's distracting people it's too much i
took this i tweeted this thing out it's
on my twitter feed somewhere um about
the gamification of trust sociological
trust and what's happening according to
this game theory study is that not that
we've been overloaded with communication
and that there's too much of it all this
new information you know the the red
pilling and the the war on terror and
the the all that but it's that the
amount of misinformation is causing
people to distrust each other
and then the cheaters the ones that are
willing to to gain that and work with
the distrust are are proliferating as a
result and if there's too much
misinformation cheaters will overwhelm
the system and then you'll have a system
of cheaters
if there's not too much just uh distrust
or misinformation then the copy the
people that are willing to kind of play
the game are gonna over override the
cheaters there are some prominent
leftist personalities who have always
claimed to be anti-fascist who are all
of a sudden now making youtube videos
being like why would anyone oppose
government mandates on forced medical
procedures and i'm like it's so weird
you know for me i've always been so in
favor of
freedoms i've always been opposed to the
coalescing of corporate power that i
find myself aligned with whoever at the
time seems to oppose the coalescing of
massive corporate and government power
so it used to be the left and all of a
sudden they're all pro corporate power
and now it's the right and i say it all
the time in a few years you know there
will be a shift backwards and the uh you
know it's people like like jack murphy a
really great example of somebody who was
a democrat now he's like democrat to
deplorable and i don't think it's that
he's a republican by party he's a
republican by you know who's willing to
support more of his ideals and i feel
that way so i have a feeling that a lot
of people like us who are like maybe in
the middle right now leaning to one side
of the other will shift back and forth
depending on which tribe wants to
actually adopt freedom and which who's
actually willing to back our natural
rights uh to what you were saying ian um
you know about this misinformation thing
people aren't able to think critically
so they're not able to differentiate
between what's you know
supposedly misinformation and what's
actually true or anything like that and
in part that's because we've completely
destroyed our educational system so
we've destroyed the canon we've
destroyed the literary canon we've taken
away
shakespeare and homer and you know all
of this other stuff that used to tell us
kind of a
timeline of this is a timeline of human
thought about ideas this is how you can
you know track truth this is how you can
understand things uh we've taken that
all away we've replaced it with stuff
that we think is appropriate to think
about now
and we've been left with a public that
doesn't know how to think clearly
because we haven't given them any
examples as to how to do so i'd like to
read a text message i received allegedly
from the aclu
i have a series of text messages from a
number from uh
well i'm not going to say the number but
it's an aclu number supposedly they say
as schools start nationwide kimberly
crenshaw talks teaching the truth about
race in america check out our podcast
back to school merch that back civil
liberties
why did the aclu text to me saying that
kimberly crenshaw is going to you know
have a podcast about back to school
stuff she is she like listen she created
intersectionalism kimberly crenshaw is
as close as you can get to being a nazi
as you can in the modern era in my
opinion when i see the stupid people
watch walking around with the symbols of
the nazi party or whatever or like the
bikers who do it because they're trying
to be you know punk or edgy or
anti-establishment that's very different
from someone who is overtly identitarian
wanting government based on race and is
a proponent of fascistic
uh ideologies whether they assert them
like verbatim or not but the people who
are like i believe the government should
have absolutely authority to do these
things and also i think the law should
be based on race okay yeah that's as
close as you can get to what the nazis
were doing so when i see some of these
prominent you know leftist youtubers
over a million subs and they're like you
know these anti-vaxxers are saying that
the vaccine mandates are bad and the
government shouldn't be doing this but
people just do what the government tells
them i'm like
so you support race-based ideology
identitarianism so does the government
you support massive multinational
pharmaceutical countries getting getting
guaranteed no liability contracts and
you support the government forcing
people to undergo medical procedures yo
you're nazis yes you're as close as you
can get to it you're at very you're at
the very least fascist yes yes i'm gonna
i'm just gonna go straight for violating
godwin's law right away
because because it's it's the look when
someone's like you know you just want
people to live the way you want because
you're a nazi it's like well well hold
on
i personally think people should take
care of their own decisions and take
care of themselves and their friends and
their families so long as they're not
hurting other people it's the it's the
dominant left democrat faction that are
basically saying pro-corporate power
guaranteed contracts for massive
unaccountable pharmaceutical countries
and the government will mandate the
medical companies
pharmaceutical countries
you said that dude are you are you
prophesying something
i know we have theocracy you see you see
what's happening because they're merging
in my mind like i'm
massive multinational corporations
say here is the product and these these
these left establishment people are
going yay save us big pharma and then
the government says and you have to buy
their product and they go yay save us
and i love it jan kyuger of the young
turk said do you think if the if the
right wingers came out and said seat
belts were tyranny that they would all
stop wearing them and i'm like yo
libertarians do think forcing people to
wear seat belts is tyranny and you know
what i remember this back in illinois
when they passed the uh the law saying
you have to wear a seat belt click it or
ticket
and what i was told i'm not saying it's
true because i was a kid at the time and
it was just the scuttle but i heard from
the adults was yeah the insurance
companies were lobbying for seat belt
laws because it
made sure their profits stayed the same
because you have to have insurance but
it meant their payouts would go down
because people were less likely to get
injured and the politicians saw it as a
safety issue and the insurance companies
saw it as a reducing their their uh you
know their their expenses issue so yes
it very well very much was in this bloom
burgarian idea of the people are too
stupid to live their own lives so the
nanny status tell them what they have to
do and now we have clicketer ticket i
hate the thing too where it's like
people are like why don't you you know
the vaccine is free just get it and it's
like it's not it's so obviously not free
the pfizer one is like 1925 a shot the
other ones are like 10 bucks or
something like that it's like my kid is
going to be paying for all of this stuff
what they were doing free vaccines for a
while but i think that ended didn't it
no i'm pretty sure it's pop-up still
free oh you could get it free at the
rite aid oh i thought you were saying it
wasn't free no it is free but it's not
free i mean it's not actually free so
the government is paying for it oh right
right right our taxes are paying so
we're paying for it and the
administration is like sending out 250 a
month to families who have kids for like
every kid
see this is weird but the thing too is
like this booster shot thing right so
now booster shots every five months yeah
so we're just gonna keep paying for that
forever it's like they finally figured
out a way to turn us all into lifelong
medical patients they've been trying to
do that for a while now and here it is
and so at a certain point your vaccine
passport is useless anyway unless you
re-up your
your dose thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you